ja eine ernsthafte Gefährdungen viele
Sprachen auch darüber inwiefern die
große Razzia 3000 Beamte waren der
notwendig um die reichsbürgerszene
aufzusprengende Festnahmen gab es der
Bundestag sollte überfallen werden ein
staats-putsch war geplant wir sind schon
mittendrin in ihrem Zimmer deswegen
haben sie gleich Ihre Kamera aber ich
möchte auch an Sie die Frage stellen
glauben Sie dass das notwendig war in
dieser Größe
ich glaube das ist notwendig war das
zeigt ja
das zeigen ja erstmal die auch die
Ergebnisse und ich finde
es ist leicht gesagt Mensch das sind ja
wirre das sind ja Spinner war das
überhaupt notwendig wenn wenn wir
Sicherheit ernst nehmen wollen wenn wir
also Gefährdungen die gefährlich sind
weil sie mit Waffen Gewalt etwas
verändern wollen wenn sie Gefährdung
nehmen die Systeme verändern wollen wenn
wir wenn wir das ernst nehmen dann muss
der Staat auch mit aller härter
reagieren und darf das nicht mit einer
gewissen Laxheit machen nach dem Motto
naja das sind ja doch irgendwie ganz
komische Leute und daher finde ich hat
man hier richtig gehandelt und es ist
auch nicht so dass die
Sicherheitsbehörden diese teilweise
abstrusen Ideen dann immer als
Begründung gebracht haben denn die
Begründung ist ja für diese ganzen
Aktionen die Bildung und Unterstützung
einer terroristischen Vereinigung und
nicht ein Umsturzversuch so und das war
mit Sicherheit gegeben und insofern
halte ich das für sehr gerechtfertigt
dass dort so eingeschritten worden ist
sie gehen sogar noch einen Schritt
weiter es gab Kritik oder auch Zweifel
an dieser Maßnahme war das wirklich
notwendig in der Größe Herr Schindler
hat gerade gesagt ja und wir haben sogar
den Beweis dafür denn es gab Festnahmen
wir sehen daran dass die Gefahr richtig
eingeschätzt wurde teilen Sie diese
Auffassung
da habe ich mich zu sehr zu wenig jetzt
muss ich sagen mit diesem konkreten Fall
beschäftigt und mein Grundvertrauen in
deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden ist schon
noch so dass ich davon ausgehe wenn egal
Generalbundesanwalt da ein Grund zieht
um da so der Weise gegen diese Person
vorzugehen dann wird es da auch eine
reale Gefahr gegeben haben aber was mich
sehr verwundert hat war dieses enorme
Medien aufgebaut
diese Top Berichterstattung in vielen
Medien die offenbar erkennen ließ dass
diese Journalisten da mindestens Tage
vorher schon Bescheid wussten und
dahinter steckt die schönsten selbst
sagen das sind ihre investigativen
Quellen die sie da haben deswegen sind
sie der top informiert ich glaube das
ist eine Art von verdeckter
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit ich weiß nicht von
wo aus aber man muss sich nur gucken
also da stecken auch Interessen von
Regierungsstellen dahinter sich in den
Medien als starker Staat zu inszenieren
und das fand ich schon befremdlich ich
habe sie kurz schnaufen hören ich weiß
nicht ob sein Lachen war aber wollen sie
darauf reagieren findet da so etwas wie
auch in bei solchen Aktionen ist
dahinter auf wie so eine Art
PR-Strategie ein Zeichen dass man setzen
will wenn Sie das erlebt
also wir müssen unterscheiden
für den Bereich Sicherheitsbehörden und
die Politik wir haben ja in den
Ministerien eine politische Führung also
das sind ja gewählte Politiker das die
Diskussion auf dieser Ebene und die
Diskussion im Parlament beispielsweise
im Innenausschuss oder im
parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium für
die Nachrichtendienste dass die
politisch geführt wird ist gut und
richtig dass dort auch
Kommunikationsstrategien man will ja
seine Politik verkaufen und will das ja
beweisen dass man es gut macht dass dort
auch Kommunikationsstrategien entwickelt
werden das finde ich auch völlig in
Ordnung das ist unser System das ist ja
auch nichts neues das ist ja nicht so
als ob zum ersten Mal Politik mit Presse
zusammenarbeitet also deshalb glaube ich
das muss man unterscheiden auf dieser
Ebene und da kann man auch dafür oder
dagegen sein ist nicht mein Thema mein
Thema ist die Sicherheitsbehörden und da
glaube ich nicht um ohne dass ich das
weiß behaupte ich
es gab niemand in den
Sicherheitsbehörden der das
durchgestochen hat wissen Sie wenn Sie
3000 Leute einsetzen alleine in
Deutschland und wer hat ja noch zwei
ausländische Partner wo das auch
durchgeführt wurde wenn sie 150
hausdurchsuchen machen das ist ein
enormer Aufwand das zu organisieren bei
der Stunde Null nämlich morgens um 6 Uhr
in die Wohnung da reinzugehen zeitgleich
das alles auszuwerten das muss
vorbereitet werden das ist sie können
sich gar nicht vorstellen wie wie lange
man daran gearbeitet hat damit das
reibungslos funktioniert und es hat
reibungslos funktioniert und das in
einer solchen Phase Journalisten die
engen Kontakt zur Sicherheit würde X
oder zur lokalen Polizei y haben dass
die irgendwann mal was mitkriegen das
versteht sich für uns selbst also so
eine große Aktion lässt sich in einer
offenen Gesellschaft wie unsere nicht
total verheimlichen ich finde es sogar
ganz gut dass wir es geschafft haben
dass keiner dieser Journalisten der das
bekommen hat vorher darüber berichtet
hat sondern dass sie sich alle dann
daran gehalten haben und erst danach
berichtet haben also ich sehe da nicht
diesen pressegau oder diesen
kommunikationsgau das in der Politik das
bisschen anders noch differenziert wird
ist mir egal aber Herr Schindler wieso
was abläuft sieht man ganz gut in dieser
Doku diesmal über die Bild-Zeitung gab
es gab noch Chef war da gibt es diese
Amazon Doku ja da gibt es eine Szene wo
Julian reichen generationskonferenz
geheimnisvoll fragt wer denn zu ihm zu
einem hintergrundtermin im
Innenministerium vertraulich mitkommt
dann darf ein junger Kollege mitgehen
der freut sich man den Termin sieht man
ja Doku nicht aber hinterher auf der
Rückfahrt oder nach wird erklärt um was
es ging da wurde er erreiche persönlich
stellte der Auflagen stärksten Zeitungen
in Deutschland persönlich vom
Innenminister weiß ich nicht aber im
Innenministerium zumindest darüber
informiert dass in den nächsten Tagen
eine groß angelegte radze gegen gegen
solche arabischen Clans gegen die klaren
Kriminalität glaube ich war das irgendwo
stattfindet
und dann hat ihre Redaktion genug Zeit
alles vorzubereiten die Live-Schaltung
und sowas und die Radzeit wird dann
wunderbar von Bild begleitet und das
Signal was der Staat damit senden will
mit Sicherheitsbehörden verkauft das ist
ich glaube es gehört zum Geschäft das
ist auch vollkommen in Ordnung dass der
Staat auch mal Härte zeigen will gegen
bestimmte Formen Signal sind will aber
ich denke kann ohne es zu wissen
vermutlich dass es in so einem in diesem
Fall sehr sehr ähnlich gelaufen ist und
das finde ich ist auch Aufgabe von
anderen Journalisten die nicht Teil
dieses Spiel sind ich gebe zu vielleicht
bin ich auch nur neidisch dass ich nicht
bescheid gesagt wurde
bitte auch
nicht nein das war Spaß ja natürlich es
gehört aber auch Aufgabe zu Journalisten
dann genau das zu hinterfragen weil man
dann schon immer die Gefahr hat dass da
auch was und deswegen war die Reaktion
so ob da vielleicht auch was aufgebaut
wird und zu einer Bedrohung zu einem
Staatsstreich äh der in Wirklichkeit
nicht zumindest nicht unmittelbar bevor
stand
sie das ganze erlebt Staat Streiche so
ein großes Wort und dann kam die ersten
Informationen man hat geplant den
Bundestag zu stürmen erstmal
unvorstellbar ja also ich habe jetzt
angewöhnt bei solchen Nachrichten dann
darauf zu hoffen dass wir dann im
Nachhinein erfahren es gibt dann ja noch
Gerichte oder so die das überprüfen die
Vorwürfe und wie geht es immer so wenn
ich so viel Verhaftung sehe dass die
Medien immer diejenigen so leid tun weil
sind ja teilweise noch nicht
ist noch nicht bewiesen die also ich
gehe davon aus genauso wie sie die
Behörden haben das Material und das muss
gemacht werden wenn jemand verhaftet
wird
so einen alten Mann sieht mit so einer
Maske dann denken
ja also ich denke man ich denke mal so
manche cool also ich sehe es auch nicht
so die Medien waren immer schon Heil
also die haben schon in den 70er Jahren
sich an die gehören geklemmt und haben
alles möglich was sie konnten schon
es war wirklich bestellt das war auch
schon immer bestellt also vom Spiegel
was wer wo der alles immer schon drin
und was alles wusste also ich glaube da
sind wir dann so naiv also so würde ich
nicht daran gehen also ich würde sagen
das ist nun mal so aber ich hoffe eben
bei dieser überbordenden Bericht
Erstattung immer dass die
Angeklagten oder die die Delinquenten
sage ich mal egal welcher Richtung sie
sind dass das dann
ja eigentlich aufgeklärt wird was jetzt
wirklich Sache ist also entweder ist es
berechtigt oder nicht aber das ist das
Einzige was wir vorher nicht wissen
können und auch nicht als Zuschauer dass
das was vielleicht die Behörde die hat
den Anfang Verdacht oder die hat schon
mehr als das und sonst würde sie nicht
zuschlagen ähm das durch die Medien
kommt eben dieses Ding rein dass wir
alle zu Hause sitzen und dann machen das
ist ja alles richtig grauenvoll und dann
das tut mir grundsätzlich in unserem
Mediengesellschaft nicht jeder tut mir
leid aber wie viele Leute geraten heute
durch zu Medien Historien in eine dann
vor Verurteilung und in dem Fall wird ja
was dran also sein sonst würden die
Behörden ja nicht zu schlagen also dann
ist der dann haben sie recht er ist
Mitleid nicht angesagt aber ich finde
das in die Medien Mühlen zu geraten
heutzutage mit Gesicht und Namen und so
weiter ist ein ein Problem mit dem wir
uns glaube ich alle irgendwie stellen
müssen das geht sehr leicht dass man
dass man durch eine Mediengeschichte und
dann denke ich mir die cool und wird man
wird irgendwann erfahren hoffentlich
hoffentlich
ob das alles so heiß gegessen wird oder
werden sollte wie man das gedacht hat
also muss man Sachen nicht bleiben würde
ich sagen